after almost 30 weeks of protest Israel
is facing the worst political crisis in
the nation's 75-year history
hundreds of thousands of Israelis are
protesting against fundamental changes
to the country's democracy
the world's Parliament has voted and
approved change a crucial aspect of the
country's Judicial System the new law
will limit the power of Supreme Court
judges
right-wing Coalition has voted to remove
one of the main checks and balances on
power critics say the bill is a threat
to democracy but many Israelis feared
the curtailing of the Supreme Court is
only laying the groundwork for more
radical plans so what exactly does
netanyahu's government want to achieve
thank you
[Music]
on July 24 the government pushed through
the first part of its controversial
judicial reform package
this law removed the power of the
Supreme Court to challenge government
decisions on the basis of whether or not
they're reasonable
foreign
[Music]
there's no second house to oversee the
decisions of the knesset of the
parliament so the Supreme Court is an
incredibly important check on the
decisions made by any one single
government this law on the
reasonableness challenge is just the
first part of a wider package of
judicial reforms one of the other really
important ones that the government wants
to enact is to change the way that
Supreme Court Justices are appointed the
government wants to be able to appoint
them which would allow them to stack the
court with people very sympathetic to
their own political views
[Music]
one of the new things to emerge from the
vote is that Netanyahu the Prime
Minister looked weak he was seen in the
kinetic trying to persuade some of his
allies to delay the vote which might
have given them a chance to come to some
kind of compromise but his allies
refused that and insisted on having the
vote on Monday that in turn raises a lot
of concerns about what those allies want
to do with the power that they now hold
[Music]
this reform gives government decisions a
far greater degree of immunity from
challenges from the Supreme Court one
question is whether the government would
like to replace the current attorney
general with someone who might be more
sympathetic for example to dropping the
corruption charges that the Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu is currently
facing charges which he strenuously
denies
that would be a controversial decision
but the Supreme Court would no longer be
able to challenge that on the basis of
whether or not it's a reasonable one
in the longer term
people are worried that this reform and
the other judicial reforms are clearing
the way for a government that includes a
variety of ultra-nationalists and Ultra
religious groups to push their policies
through whether that be in relation to
the Palestinians in relation to the role
of religion in Israel's daily life or
other institutions as part of Israel's
democracy one of the immediate concerns
is about the support for settlers in the
West Bank from parties within the
government we've seen them speaking in
support of the kind of violent
vigilantism that has been happening in
the West Bank recently and the concern
is that these legal reforms will clear
the way for those who want to escalate
this
[Music]
I'm Josie de la The Economist Middle
East Editor to read more of our coverage
of Israel please click on the link thank
you for watching and don't forget to
subscribe
[Music]